[Music]
anyone here have the iPhone I'm sure you
do you have the iPhone okay it's a big
you're booing the iPhone angry tech
nerdy I bring us up for a reason big
week for Apple on Friday did you know
this the iPhone turns five years old in
other words the iPhone is now officially
old enough to build an iPhone
people just they don't laugh a child
labor like the youth I find it amusing
hilarious little kids making things yeah
great today the FDA approved a new
anti-obesity drug yeah to make sure
Americans take it and come to the side
of onion rings fed ranch-flavored yeah a
boxing promoter has offered drake and
chris brown 1 million dollars to settle
their differences in the ring yet Chris
Brown said the fight will never happen
unless he and Drake start dating
a new study I don't know if I believe
this but a new study came out that shows
that posting on Facebook is as enjoyable
as sex yeah this yeah the study was
conducted by people who were either
really bad at sex or way too good at
Facebook do you anything that good yeah
what like cool by the way that's what
happens to me that's the most
embarrassing thing I've ever revealed
about myself it's being reported that
last night in New York Charlie Sheen
trashed his hotel room it's not amazing
people are still renting hotel rooms to
Charlie Sheen it's insane
who shows him the room and shows him
nothing and here it is and we trust you
and goodbye now if I is your donkey and
your cocaine and we're gonna come back
later what every Hotel should just have
a pre trashed room for you please put
him in that one that's what I do
speaking of New York today in Manhattan
a woman gave birth to a healthy baby boy
while riding the subway nice which by
the way made him the sixth guy on the
New York subway today to show his penis
that's a slow day only six the weather
was in Clement yeah according to reports
yesterday the Kardashians went shopping
for a family cemetery plot the
Kardashians plan on dying as they've
lived lying on their backs doing nothing
[Applause]